le César du meilleur acteur est attribué
à
Benoît Magimel il réussit un carton
plein de César pour dénominations en
cette catégorie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui est totalement irréel
c'est encore mieux la troisième fois je
crois que ça c'est merci à Albert serra
merci merci à mes mes compatriotes
polynésiens qui m'ont donné la réplique
qui me l'accompagnait qui vont nourrit
voilà merci
franchement c'est beau ça fait vraiment
du bien et
je pensais pas avoir autant de liberté
comme acteur là sur ce film je sais pas
que ça pouvait être possible d'être
aussi libre en fait tout simplement et
voilà je suis
je remercie l'Académie je remercie les
votants
ce soir est un moment assez assez
fou et voilà je suis très touché je
dédie à mon père ce soir c'est César et
puis
voilà tous ceux que j'aime merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]